des cyclistes ont bataillé ce weekend
sur la piste du vélodrome national de 50
ans en iblin 120 sportifs venus de toute
la France ont participé ce dimanche 27
novembre au Grand Prix de véisi un
rendez-vous créé en 2014 qui fêtait
cette année sa 9e édition et qui s'est
installé dans le paysage du cyclisme
francilien on a toujours un petit espoir
lorsqu'on lance une une épreuve donc ben
10 ans après c'est c'est une petite
fierté et ça dure parce que notre
épreuve qui est une une épreuveocation
régionale nationale s'inscrit
parfaitement dans le paysage de la piste
français à ce jour plusieurs centaines
de cyclistes ont participé à cet
événement autonnal la petite
satisfaction des organisateurs tous les
membres de l'équipe de France sur piste
actuel ont couru au moins une fois le
Grand Prix de véizi un rendez-vous
révélateur de talent parmi les futurs
espoirs on retrouve ce dimanche la
nouvelle championne du monde de
poursuite par équipe la p star de 17 ans
Léonie Mailleux là c'est une bonne
occasion pour rencontrer l'équipe
apprendre à fonctionner ensemble même si
on a déjà roulé ensemble auparavant puis
de se mettre tranquillement en route et
de faire un un bon bloc pendant l'hiver
pour se préparer dès janvier quand les
les les grosses compétitions vont
reprendre toutes les catégories étaient
représentées sur cette édition le
champion du monde Masters de scratch
était notamment présent dans l'air
centrale il participa à son deuxème
Grand Prix de véisie c'est vraiment une
belle occasion de de se faire ses armes
voilà sur un niveau assez relevé l'année
dernière j'étais en Access et là j'ai
couru en Open et voilà une belle
occasion de de concourir le Grand Prix
de véisi reviendra l'année prochaine
pour une 10e édition les organisateur
espèrent attirer encore plus de têtes
d'affiche